it's been a long time since you've done
any math
so let's just remember what we're doing
that leads up to this because they
really do they really are
one piece okay yeah okay fantastic the
last thing
we were looking at was things like this
sine
two theta cos two theta
tan two theta what we learnt was a
series of identities that
allow us to work with these things but
we said these are kind of like a bridge
to elsewhere like we're not memorizing
these just for their own sake okay
they're heading in a certain direction
so let's see if we can remember what are
the identities
for each of these in terms of no two
theta's just
single thetas okay yeah give me one
let's
see good two
side cos perfect all right someone else
give me the next one yeah
squared theta minus seven fantastic cos
squared theta
but it's sine squared not to be confused
with the pythagorean identity which is
plus okay and the last one which i'll
give you a clue
fraction like yeah right theta
minus 10 squared excellent
okay so here are the identities now
these were learned kind of on the tail
of a whole bunch of other identities
like your brain is kind of slowly
expanding at least i hope it is
with all the identities that you know in
fact it's starting to get to the
point where it's overwhelming how many
you know
so when you get given a question which
is like a trigger identity prove that
this
equals this okay you've got so many to
choose from sometimes the hardest thing
is just
okay which identities do i pick there's
so many that i can use
okay so we're going to take that idea
when you've got a trig identity you know
uh left hand side is exactly equal to
the right hand side right we're going to
take that as our first kind of
opportunity to see a useful application
of these
right in particular this one
so this subtopic is called t results
because it comes from
the tan identity and the letter that's
going to use the pretty rule that gets
used over and over again because it
stands for tan
is t right so let's take this thing here
if i replace every single angle in that
line there
right every single angle here instead of
theta if i replace it with theta on 2
half theta okay what will happen let's
have a look at the left hand side first
if instead of theta i have half theta
then 2 times half theta
will just be theta right so on the left
hand side i'll have
tan theta on the right hand side all the
theta's i'm going to replace with
half theta so i'll get on the top 2 10
theta on 2. nothing dramatic there
and one minus 10 squared
theta on two now this doesn't seem like
it's done anything
dramatic yet it hasn't okay but as
you'll see
this is kind of one angle to take which
unlocks all these other options that
we've got right
and this is a bit awkward to work with
and this guy here tan and theta on two
it's going to come up a lot so instead
of writing tan theta on two
every single time we're going to say let
tan theorem two let it equal to
t so this is the t on which t results
from which t results is named okay so i
can say therefore
tan theta equals two t on one
minus t squared okay
now there's tan an expression for tan
and now it's in terms of algebra
algebra is great we started the year
looking at algebra it's great because
it's powerful and you're very very very
good at it your brains have spent
years mastering this okay so if we can
kind of like leverage your
ability with algebra to become better
intrigued that's a really really good
thing okay
so if i've got tan i mean naturally i
probably want siding cos
as well right so i'm going to show you
two ways to
come up with how do you say sine and cos
in terms of this t business i'm going to
show you a cheap fast way
which will be handy to remember and then
i'm going to show you a more thorough
way which
you'll see why we'll need to throw away
in a second okay so
look at this line here right this is
really important this is kind of like
your definition
of the the first t result for which we
get all the rest
okay this kind of implies something
tan when you first learn the trig
functions right they're actually trig
ratios right so this kind of implies
there's a triangle
and there are some sides in that
triangle that are in this ratio
okay so for instance over here you can
make a little subheading which is a
quick proof
this implies a right angle triangle and
if i put theta
in one of the corners like say this one
okay
10 is opposite on adjacent right
opposite
adjacent okay so if theta's here in the
bottom left hand corner
then this is my opposite side so over on
the right
here and this is my adjacent side down
here
okay now using these two and i'm in a
right angle
triangle i can use pythagoras to work
out
this guy over here can i it's the
hypotenuse okay so let's just call him
h for high bodies the hypotenuse squared
is the sum of the squares of the other
two sides right so i've got a 2t
all squared there and a 1 minus
t squared squared there yep so far so
good
so let's expand this guy here what am i
going to get from this
2t all squared before t squared right
what do i have here i'm going to have 1
minus
two t squared plus t
to the four okay and you can see we do a
little bit of
uh simplification here i'm gonna leave
that one out the front
what happens with these guys like terms
plus
two t squared see that and then i've got
that
plus t and the four on the end okay
now use your algebra brain here this
here
this is a perfect square isn't it it's
in the form a squared plus two a b
plus b squared right in fact it's almost
identical
to this the only difference is
there's a plus in the middle see that
so there is my hypotenuse squared
so if that's that and remember the
hypothesis is a length should be
positive
i'm getting this from pythagoras okay
so i started with these two sides
algebraically i got to this one
okay so now i've got all an interest
signing cos
right tan gave me the opposite adjacent
for sine and cos i'll just need the
hypotenuse right
so on the basis of this triangle i can
say
sine theta is equal to i'm still here
right opposite on hypotenuse right
two t on one plus t
squared and in the same way
cos will be adjacent
on hypotenuse bigger okay so
let's just highlight and summarize what
we've done here we have
introduced this guy here
tan there on two and made that t okay if
you call that t
you can get all your other trig
functions in terms of
t right so there's tan theta in terms of
t
there's scythia and there's
cosine theta all right so this is really
nice
right i'm going to show you in a minute
how we're going to use this and why it's
kind of handy again it's like taking
advantage of how good you are
algebra but i did say
this is a quick proof right it's not the
best trip there's a big glaring hole
with it
any takers looked at things like this
before
yeah yeah very good so
my whole premise the place i started
right is
it's in a right angled triangle which
immediately puts a restriction
on theta namely what restrictions do i
have on theta if i'm going to write a
triangle yeah between zero and nine
good so i have this uh i'll put it up
here
it can't be equal yeah sorry a bit of
triangle
okay in other words theta's acute okay
so this proof only works for theta
being a q it's still very
valuable though that's why i'm showing
it to you in fact it's the way that i
remember
and make sure that i get these fractions
in the right order okay because they you
can see they're kind of easy to confuse
with each other
so these results are all still true but
let me really quickly show you a more
thorough way of doing it it's just
not as obvious